I love my looks even more than my
children so it's even worse gotta love
Blake Lively always a jokester even when
it comes to Couture or her kids I can't
pick a favorite it's like picking a
favorite kid the actress stepped out to
support Tiffany and Co at their
reopening of the landmark in New York
City and conversation turned to the
upcoming Met Gala which she won't be
attending this year so when E.T asked
Blake to pick a favorite past look from
Fashion's biggest night well she gave us
this hilarious analogy
it's like picking a favorite kid except
I love my looks even more than my
children so it's even worse
for Blake it was Mom's Night Out she
looked stunning in a brown leather dress
and of course Tiffany Jewels I'm walking
rocking some uh vintage pieces which are
really special and then this snake
because come on isn't that sexy isn't
that amazing I feel like it's just like
a casual day piece like I could just
wear this with a t-shirt I should just
like I'm gonna start getting coffee
every morning just so I have an excuse
to wear them Blake told E.T the faint
jewelry designer holds a special place
in her heart sharing the first time she
bought herself a gift in that iconic
blue box it was when I got my first job
this is sort of the Traveling Pants and
I was like what are you gonna do for
yourself that will be something that
will last for your lifetime and I bought
the ball bracelet you know like with the
little I couldn't afford the one with
the heart you know that said Tiffany and
Coke I might have had a knockoff of that
when I was you know like I don't know in
sixth grade but we don't talk about that
[Music]
thank you
foreign